the first one like okay i'll tell you it
was last section hero the movie
ironically that eliza was in
as a kid um and i was a caterer
to the movie premiere and um i was
catering for the food
and then i went on a break and it went
around my table and
arnold schwarzenegger came at me came
towards me to go
to the table i guess but somebody else
had taken over and i'm faced with him
face-to-face i'm looking at him he's
looking at me i can't speak
he he's looking at me expecting me
probably to say something
i don't say anything and then he turns
to his people because he had like
a round of people around him and says
where's the food
and i was like i lost it now cut two
years later
i'm at the expendables world premiere at
planet hollywood in las vegas
arnold and and sly are like best friends
we're backstage about to go into the
main stage
and and arnold's there
and i end up approaching him and going i
met you that a long long time ago
you there's no way you would remember
this and he didn't
but i remember you hated the food i was
so hungry
i'm so hungry and then um i said
um i did want to tell you something i
said when i was at playhouse west
one of the a part of the curriculum was
that you had to read 1500 pages a week
and do a book report at the end of every
week
so that you could learn something
and also be able to um glean from a
script
the essence of the story like that you
could understand what a story was and
you knew what good writing was
they had a they had a reading list but
anyway on
you could also read any autobiography so
i read his
and i said to him you know one of the
most lasting impressions i had of
reading one of your books was
when you met um maria shriver's dad
he'd ask you what do you do and he went
to answer and he goes no what do you do
to help
people and i just thought that was such
a powerful thing
wow and i've never forgotten it
and while i was talking to him
rosie i swear to god like laser
sharp focus he makes you feel like
there's nobody else in the room he has
a thing in it this
it's not quantifiable you can't even i
can't even identify what it is
but it's this ability to 110
focus listen super intently
i don't know what's going on his mind
everybody's it's super loud where we
were and it was like
super sharp focus on everything i was
saying and he was just
he commented back that like that was a
very memorable he was like really glad
that i read the book and
so flattered and yes it was awesome
thing and
you know he was very very congenial it
was
really made an impression on me so
meeting schwarzenegger you're that's
that's the one thing star struck when i
met schwarzenegger
and then you read his book and you got
were you so excited i bet you were just
like this book when i was a kid
right and then you got you wanted to
come up you're like you had something to
talk about
so many times people come up to actors
or whatever and
they're like hey but like it's it's cool
i mean i love when people have something
to
say to me i'm very cool if they don't
but it's nice if they say
hey i read this no i didn't read that
because you didn't write a book
uh you know but it's not it's definitely
nice when they have some kind of like
question or something that
to say it was nice that you got a little
star struck and he
gave you his undivided attention i like
that yeah he was great
he was he was a great he
gives he makes you feel
heard that's nice yeah i think that's
important to be heard you know
i said this before but like what he said
where maria shriver's father
said to him what do you do no what do
you do for people like what do you do
what do you like what importance do you
bring you know it's like that saying
where
it's not what you do on camera to look
like oh look i'm so giving i'm talking
to this kid i'm helping but
what do you do when the cameras are off
you know that's that shows the real
individual and i think that's really
important and i've learned from that
i've learned to
because you always when the camera's
rolling turn it on rosie
you know be the cheese ball oh look oh
we're here
but it's when the cameras are off and
you could really make a difference
you know and um those are the moments
that i
that the moments that only i know about
with certain people or certain kids or
you know driving out to some family's
house to have dinner or
and it's just me and nobody else knows
except now you
those are the moments that i'm like this
is this gives you purpose
you know